so this newest form of Leverage is where
all the new fortunes are made so all the
new billionaires the last generation
fortunes were made by Capital that was
the Warren buffets of the world but the
new generation fortunes Are All Made
through code or media
the most interesting and the most
important form of Leverage is this idea
of products that have no marginal cost
of replication this is the new form of
Leverage this is only invented in the
last few hundred years it got started
with the printing press it accelerated
broadcast media and now it's really
blown up with the internet and with code
so now you can multiply your efforts
without having to involve other humans
and without needing money from other
humans this podcast is a form of
Leverage long ago I would have had to
sit in a lecture hall and lecture each
of you personally and I would have maybe
reached a few hundred people and that
would have been that 30 years ago I
would have to be lucky to get on TV
which is somebody else's leverage they
would have distorted the message that
would have taken the economics out of it
or charge me for it they would have
muddled the message and I would have
been lucky to get that form of Leverage
but today thanks to the internet I can
buy a cheap microphone hook it up to a
laptop or an iPad and there you are all
listening so this newest form of
Leverage is where all the new fortunes
are made so all the new billionaires the
the last generation fortunes were made
by Capital that was the Warren buffets
of the world but the new generation
fortunes Are All Made through code or
media Joe Rogan making 50 to 100 million
bucks a year from his podcasts PewDiePie
I don't know how much money he's rolling
in but he's bigger than the news right
the fortnite players of course Jeff
Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
and Sergey Brin and Bill Gates and Steve
Jobs that is all code based leverage now
the beauty is when you combine all of
these three that's where Tech startups
really Excel where you take just the
minimum but highest output labor that
you can get which are engineers and
designers product developers and then
you add in capital you use that for
marketing advertising scaling and you
add in lots of code and media and
podcasts and content to get it all out
there that is a magic combination and
that's why you see technology startups
explode out of nowhere use massive
Leverage and just make huge outsize
returns
do you want to talk a little bit about
permissioned versus permissionless
probably the most interesting thing to
keep in mind about the new forms of
Leverage is they are permissionless they
don't require somebody else's permission
for you to use them or succeed for labor
leverage somebody has to decide to
follow you for Capital leverage somebody
has to give you money to invest or to
turn into a product but coding writing
books recording podcasts tweeting
youtubing these kinds of things these
are permissionless you don't need
anyone's permission to do them and
that's why they're very egalitarian
they're great equalizers of Leverage and
as much as people may rail on Facebook
and YouTube they're not going to stop
using it because this permissionless
leverage where everyone can be a
broadcaster is just too good the same
way you know you can rail upon Apple for
having a slightly closed ecosystem in
the iPhone but everyone's writing apps
for it and so as long as you can write
apps for it you can get rich or reach
users doing that why not I think of all
the forms of Leverage the best one in
modern society and people gonna this is
glib this is a little overused but and
this is why I tell people learn to code
right it's that we have this idea that
in the future there's going to be these
robots and they're going to be doing
everything and that may be true but I
would say the majority of the robot
revolution has already happened the
robots are already here and there are
way more robots than they're humans it's
just that we pack them in data centers
for heat and efficiency reasons we put
them in servers they're inside the
computers all the circuits the robot
mind inside that's doing all the work
and so every great software developer
for example now has an army of robots
working for him at night time while he
or she sleeps after they've written the
code and it's just cranking away so the
robot's Army is already here the robot
revolution has already happened we're
about halfway through it we're just
adding in much more of the hardware
component these days as we get more
familiar we get more comfortable with
the idea of autonomous vehicles and
autonomous airplanes and autonomous
ships and maybe autonomous trucks and
you know their delivery Bots and Boston
Dynamics robots and all that but robots
who are doing web searching for you for
example are already here you know the
ones who are like cleaning up your your
video and audio and transmitting around
the world are already here the ones who
are answering many customer service
queries things that you would have had
to call human for are already here so an
army of robots is already here it's very
cheaply available and the bottleneck is
just figuring out intelligent and
interesting things to do to them and
essentially you can order this Army of
robots around just the commands have to
be issued in a computer language in the
language that they understand so these
robots aren't very smart they have to be
told very precisely what to do and how
to do it so coding is such a great
superpower because now you can speak the
language of the robot armies and you can
tell them what to do most of my growth
came actually after uh I graduated high
school basically what I did was I
somehow found these other like four
lunatics we were three of us were
College dropouts one was a high school
dropout and one I don't know he just
like quit his job we're all super small
YouTubers and we basically talked every
day for a thousand days in a row and did
nothing but just like hyper study like
what makes a good video what makes a
good thumb know what what's good pacing
like how to go viral and we would just
call it like daily masterminds we would
just get on Skype every morning and like
some days like I'd get on Skype at seven
a.m and I'd be in the call until like 10
pm and then I'd go to bed I wake up and
I do it again and you know we do things
like take a thousand thumbnails and see
if like there's a correlation to the
brightness of the thumbnail to how many
views it got or like you know like
videos that get over 10 million views
it's like how often do they cut the
camera angles or like things like that
yeah so you you micro analyzed
everything yeah just I mean for like we
were very religious about it and so
that's that's where most of my knowledge
came from is I just surround myself with
these lunatics and just every day like
we didn't do anything we had no life uh
but everybody had sort of a similar
Vision yeah exactly so we all had like
10 20 000 subscribers when we met and by
the time we stopped talking we all had
millions of subscribers and we we all
hit a million subscribers like within a
month it's crazy because it's like if
you envision a world where you're trying
to be great at something and it's just
like you learning and [ __ ] up and
learning from your mistakes also so my
mom told me not to curse sorry Mom if
someone could just like edit out the
swear words and give it to me Mom yeah
so I could give it to my mom to listen
to that would be great
um but like you know you mess up you
learn from your mistake you mess up you
learn from your mistake you in two years
you know might have learned from 20
mistakes or if you have like four other
people who are also messing up and when
they uh learn from the mistake they
teach you what they learn stuff like
that hypothetically you two years down
the road have learned like five times
more of the amount of stuff so it just
like helps you grow exponentially way
quicker if that makes any sense it does
it does how do you think the money is
best spent for the channel in terms of
growth yes
okay how do I think it's best spent just
making the best YouTube videos possible
I mean if we want to sell more feasibles
bars or merge or get better brand deals
it all literally just stems around you
know people watching the videos which is
does that go back then to more idea
creation or do you think it's higher
retention so better Specialists or or I
guess yeah okay it's it's more like
those things help but they're it's not
like at the end of the day like it's
like you know we put 100 girls in a
circle versus 100 boys half a million
dollar cash prize build these crazy sets
all the effort that's a big part of why
it does well right sure we can tweak a
little bit here and there and and remove
a p joke so it's a little bit more
watchable and and do this little thing
but at the end of the day it's like
that's not why people are coming back
and that's not what makes it great
that's just a little icing on top you
know what I mean yeah so like the money
is best spent in like just doing grander
things that I find interesting that are
unique original and like people just how
I would put it can't find anywhere else
so you can't find what we do do for the
most part some videos here and there but
for the most part you can't find what we
do anywhere else not at the scale we do
and I think it's like that is where I
want to put the money in because then
that's what gets people coming back they
enjoy it and then everything else
benefits are you investing any of your
own money separate from everything else
like do you take any of it for yourself
put it off to the side reinvest
everything I want to just literally all
I want to do is make the best food as
possible that's why I live in the studio
right over there so I don't like I'm not
worried about paying for a mansion I
don't drive a Lamborghini
um I purposely have a really like dumbed
down lifestyle so when because it gives
you Freedom like you know most people
can't reinvest in a business because
when they get to this level they're
worried about their 10 million dollar
mansion they're like four or five cars
and insurance and keeping up with that
and then like their second home and all
these other things I just cut it all out
I have no like personal debt or like
things you know that I have to pay for
so I can just go all in on the business
because it's like it doesn't even matter
you know what I mean can you talk about
maybe investing in nfts or crypto if you
want to talk about that no I mean
literally all I do is I invest in my
videos right now so I actually don't
even do any investing on the side
um back in the day you know I bought a
little bit of Bitcoin
um and did pretty good but then I ended
up just dumping it back into the videos
so you're at the top and you're the guy
who was calling the shots and it's your
channel but it seems like you've got a
whole ecosystem under you of course and
you're [ __ ] 23 years old I mean
that's wild [ __ ] to be managing I I
could step away and those guys could
create just the most viral videos ever
we have a machine these people are
geniuses I mean it I I lucked out with
quite a few of them they're really
intelligent the way you put them
together was just finding people that
you thought were interesting I mean how
long did it take to develop a 100
employee roster yeah well not all 100
are on the main channel right because
like uh we have the gaming channel which
probably has like 24 people like on our
gaming channel we have like five four or
five people that like their full-time
job is just to build the maps like
everything we do in Minecraft we custom
build and we cost some code stuff and
then we have a dozen people that work on
a React channel the main show I don't
know where we're at but uh it's probably
like half of it
um and I don't know they're just like
the people they just come from
everywhere I don't even know how to
explain because it's like I basically
just hired one person a month every
month for like the last five years
essentially wow you're in the middle of
all this and you have all the stuff
going on whether it's the Social Media
stuff and the filming stuff and the
coming up with the new content new ideas
and then managing the fact you have a
hundred [ __ ] people well we haven't
even gotten into the side companies or
the side channels either no the Beast
burgers and all that jazz yeah first of
all where's Mr Beast Burger how many of
them do you have uh so right now we
don't have any physical we have 1600
virtual restaurants oh so you order it
online and then they deliver it yeah so
like uh let's say you own a mom and pop
restaurant you you literally just sign
up uh go through the course you learn
how to make all the stuff on a menu and
you just order our ingredients in our
packaging and then you just flick it on
on ubereats doordash GrubHub and you can
start taking orders and we let you keep
a majority of the revenue so it's based
basically like it's a win-win for
restaurants especially when covet first
hit it was like huge for a lot of
restaurants because I was pushing it
really hard back then and like some
restaurants you were literally laying
off people and they started uh serving
Beast burger and some of them doing like
10 grand a week uh not like in total
revenues whatever their cut was lower
but it allowed them to not have to like
lay off part of their Workforce or keep
their employees and stuff like that
um and and so yeah and this idea came
out of what uh we were approached by
some company and no more I thought about
the more I just realized it was just a
great idea so we have a partner I got
basically a guy who's been doing
restaurants his whole life he so
actually that's how he started because
he owned 300 restaurants so we launched
with three his 300 restaurants and like
that first day they all sold out they
were having like run to local stores to
buy ingredients to keep up with orders
like the ubereats like delivery lines
were like out the door it was it was
pretty bad so we had to like quickly
expand up
um and we've just been adding like 50
restaurants a week ever since wow yeah
and so now we're about to start doing
our first physical restaurants as well
and that should be fun your mom must be
so baffled a kid she thought wasn't
doing jack shirts
virtual restaurants it's incredible man
that's yeah it's actually insane and so
we've been doing it for like probably
like 15 months now and we're about to
cross uh 100 million in top line revenue
across the restaurants wow so that's one
side business what other side businesses
do you have so we just launched our
snack brand
um just our first thing is a chocolate
bar it's uh just basically like only
four ingredients just a slightly
healthier version of chocolate bar
problems if you make things too healthy
which is what I found with my restaurant
because I I would love to wean people
off like super unhealthy stuff but if
you like we did lettuce wrap like we
just replaced the bun with lettuce no
one orders it if you go like too extreme
in the healthy side just no one cares
um so it's like I found like the best
spot is just to make things like 20
healthier and then people still order it
if not then it's just useless
um so I wanted to do a snack brand and
I'm experimenting with that so it's just
basically a slightly better for you
chocolate bar just higher quality
ingredients a little bit less
ingredients what do you put in it um
well you just pull it out there it is Mr
Beast bar I mean like I said it's not
crazy healthy but
um and yeah it's got quinoa on it yeah
um I love that one I know I have some
out there I'll have you a taste tester I
think I'm sure it's good quinoa mixed
with chocolate bro they put chocolate on
ants and people eat it you know I mean
everything with chocolate is good well
and so our our big marketing stuff for
this because everything I do it's Gotta
you know the spectacle is 10 random
people are going to get flown down to
commute for a chocolate factory in a
video
um and yeah so we're still working I'm
building the Chocolate Factory that's
what I was doing yesterday before I flew
out here
foreign
s require leverage business leverage
comes from Capital people and products
with no marginal cost of replication
code and media apply specific knowledge
with leverage and eventually you will
get what you deserve Navara vacant to
watch the video on specific knowledge
click on the link at the top right
corner the cool thing about Leverage is
that it fundamentally distorts this
relationship between your input and the
output that you get the relationship
becomes non-linear in nature and your
input once it's done is attached from
the output because it is detached from
the marginal delivery of your product
service every time that a customer or
viewer consumes it using leverage you
might work on some project for one day
or one year and that can potentially
bring an output that people without
leverage couldn't get in 10 years or a
lifetime this is why you cannot get rich
renting out your time you must own
something run it on a form or forms of
Leverage and apply your specific
knowledge forget reach versus poor white
color versus blue it's now leveraged
versus on Leverage
now I want to share some quotes that
always help me when doing any big
personal project the pessimist may sound
intelligent but is The Optimist who
makes money Peter Lynch after a lifetime
of making money and observing better man
and woman than I Fall by the wayside I'm
convinced that fear of failing in the
eyes of the world is the single biggest
impediment to amassing wealth trust me
on this Felix Dennis the need for
certainty is the greatest disease the
Mind faces Robert Greene most people
will choose some happiness over
uncertainty Tim Ferris thanks for
watching if you enjoyed the notes
Reflections and quotes in this video you
will likely also find valuable or
newsletter fresh nuggets where you can
receive in your email all my notes and
thoughts every time I upload a new video
it is free forever and it's super easy
to sign up and if you don't find it
valuable it's also super easy to
unsubscribe from it so if you want to
check it out and maybe have a look at my
previous articles please find the link
below in the description
[Music]
welcome